hey guys Greg knuckles here for string
theory calm string with an E and J th
string calm and today we are talking
about work capacity first off what is
work capacity in essence it is the
maximum amount of work that you can do
in the gym and recover from and respond
positively to now why is it important
because not to overstate things it is
the cornerstone of long term progress in
the gym
overtime you simply have to do more work
to continue getting results it's a very
basic principle of exercise physiology
known as the repeated bouts effect that
when you do the same thing over and over
and over your body adapts to it and
essentially doesn't respond as robustly
to it as it once did so over time you
simply have to do more to keep making
progress and that's why we're capacity
is so important because the amount of
work you can maximally do right now is
probably not as much work as you would
need to do to reach your long-term
potential so essentially it's a ceiling
on the amount of work you can do so if
your ceilings here now that's going to
cap how much progress you can make so
you need to raise that ceiling over time
to keep getting bigger and stronger so
that dovetails into a discussion about
plateaus essentially what happens with a
plateau is you're working out you're
doing basically the same stuff weekend
in week out you're making progress for a
while and then you hit a wall and stop
making progress and that pretty much
happens because the amount of work you
need to do to keep making progress is
more than the amount of work you're
currently doing so the simplest way to
keep moving forward is simply to do more
work I've written about that before I'll
link the article in the description so
anyway you need to do more work so that
works for a while as long as the amount
of work you need to do to keep moving
forward is Bo
hello your work capacity the ceiling of
the amount of work you can do so you
know you hit a plateau you do more work
you make more progress you have another
plateau you do more work you make more
progress and that's all well and good
until the amount of work you need to do
is bumping up against your work capacity
and what happens at that point is since
work capacity is the maximal amount you
can do and recover from and adapt
positively to if you end up needing to
do more than that to make progress then
when you increase your workload above
that threshold essentially you can't
recover from it and respond positively
to it anymore and that's when
overreaching or overtraining starts to
set in so from that point the only way
forward is to increase your work
capacity so that's where your aerobic
system comes in because it's the main
driver of how much energy your body can
produce to fuel that work so if you know
let's say you're doing sets of five or
so and it takes you five minutes to
recover between sets but you only have
you know an hour to to work out and the
amount of work you need to do to keep
moving forward is greater than the
amount of work you can cram into that
time period because you're so gassed
after sets then acutely your aerobic
metabolism the amount of energy your
aerobic system can produce is limiting
your work capacity and how much training
you can do there are also chronic
limiters to work capacity and they
mainly have to do with how well you can
recover between workouts a big one is
how resilient your body is to muscle
damage the more you train the less
muscle damage is caused by a given
workload so your body has to do less to
recover from that and kind of on the
flip side of that is how efficiently
your body can synthesize the protein
necessary to recover from a given
workload also your muscles and tendons
resiliency to a given level and amount
of loading that you know essentially
pushes that increases the amount of work
you can do before your muscles and
tendons and joints start feeling beaten
up by the amount of training you have to
do to keep moving forward and another
thing for recovery between sessions is
your autonomic nervous system the more
parasympathetic you are that's your rest
in digest system as opposed to
sympathetic that's your item flight
fight or flight system the more
parasympathetic you are the more robust
of a recovery state your body is in
between workouts finally we're going to
talk about how to increase work capacity
a lot of this just has to do with basic
smart periodization if you've been
training pretty similarly for a long
period of time you've been increasing
your volume you finally hit a plateau
and your lifts aren't going anywhere
you're not getting any bigger or any
stronger then what you have to do is if
you're using block periodization terms
cycle back and do what would be called
an accumulation block or if you aren't
big on terminology basically just doing
more work and lowering the weights
you're working with well the average
weights you're working with there are
two ways to accomplish this number one
is simply to keep training with the same
basic setup you are now but to decrease
training weights anywhere from 5 to 15
percent and increase the amount of total
reps you're doing in a workout so you're
handling a larger training volume the
other way is to shift the emphasis of
your training and to make it less
specific as to the lifts you're trying
to increase so if you know 60 70 percent
of your training now is just squat bench
and deadlift or variations thereof you
can flip that around to maybe make that
20 30 percent of your training being the
main lifts and still keep training them
heavy
but then put a greater emphasis on
accessory work that allows you to handle
a higher total training volume in terms
of implementation that phase would last
anywhere from two to four months
depending on your level as a lifter for
someone who's more of a beginner
intermediate hitting their first major
plateaus that might be two months for
someone in more advanced that might be
three four months maybe even a little
bit longer and now during that period
your goal should still be to progress in
a measurable fashion except typically
you would be progressing by trying to
increase the amount of weights you have
on the bar but during that period you
would be trying to progress by
increasing your weekly workload week to
week and just as a general rule of thumb
of five to ten percent increase in
workload week to week is a good place to
start so over three months twelve weeks
of training that would be increasing
your workload roughly 60 to 120 percent
and doubling your workload that may
sound like a lot but when you really get
into it it's it's not nearly as bad as
it sounds especially because you're
decreasing the loading of it and finally
it may be necessary to increase the
amount of cardiovascular work you're
doing simply to increase the aerobic
base to fuel this type of training and
for that I would recommend basic low
intensity steady-state cardio interval
training seems to be in vogue lately but
during this period remember what you're
trying to do is increase the stress on
your body to long term increase the
amount of stress it can handle and
things like sprints those are other very
stressful that's another very stressful
exercise both for your muscles and your
nervous system so you'd be better served
there just a incline treadmill walk low
intensity steady-state on a bike trying
to keep your heart rate 125 to 140 for
25 to 60 minutes or so two to three
times a week um
that will help improve your aerobic
conditioning without significantly
limiting your ability to recover between
training sessions so that's all for
today guys hope you enjoyed it if you
did please like and subscribe check out
my website string theory calm and jth
strength calm or I'm the Content Manager
and also please check out the link in
the description this is basically a
video version of an article that I had
written previously so if you want to dig
into this subject a little bit more
check that out
thanks guys